no
the metropolitan police revealed that
homicides in the popular tourist stretch
known as the strip have increased that
such health told cristian casares
that most of these
homicides occurred during the months
of april and august police say that the
crime rate increased  when
hotels began to reopen and more
criminals from out of state came to
the city so metro has launched
operations to fight crime
so far this year metro has made 44 thousand
stops in the script and have made 8000
arrests and confiscated 600  Guns A
woman is safe and sound this morning
after she was kidnapped by her ex-boyfriend
the incident escalated to a
shooting near charleston island in the
northeast valley the woman was
kidnapped near lake mls and jones on
tuesday morning police  managed to
locate the couple east of the valley
when officers tried to defuse the
situation the man pointed a gun and
officers fired at him  and died at the
scene detectives are still investigating
this case
authorities are looking for the person
responsible for killing a dog
near the south and baseball and the
humane society is
offering $5,000 for
information that will help apprehend the
suspect if you  You have any kind
of details, you are asked to call crime
stoppers and the
Las Vegas Convention and Visitors Authority approved the
sale of the land where
the Riviera hotel was previously located, on the
streets of the Convention Center, Los Lakers,
back, near the PSOE, which is
and from the new resorts world a
chilean investment company bought the property
for 120 million dollars the
construction project will begin in 2031
timao barinas luxury service last night
where fans received the golden
knights with a flourish the knights
opened their fifth season  in a
full house facing those who
wanted the game was intense until
the final where the knights won by
only one point 4 to 3 in their first
game of the season and there is no doubt
that autumn has made its presence the
temperatures have dropped a lot with the
highs in the c for the weekend it will
warm up a bit  more with discharges
reaching 80 for Sunday and next week I
am Cristian Cásseres with his but
informative news now in Spanish good
day